des championnats de france presque à
domicile la gemme elancourt mort pas
connu cela pour la toute première fois
de son histoire
ce samedi 25 et dimanche 26 mai les
athlètes du club devaient concourir à
moins de 10 kilomètres de leur lieu
d'entraînement au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines devant
plusieurs milliers de spectateurs
d'abord ses amis sa famille qui sont la
dernière roue alors qu'habituellement en
provence il se déplacera forcément ça
fera bien un stress supplémentaire et
une pression supplémentaire pour les
plus jeunes parfois mais je pense que
sur ses jeunes fils à elle seule après
une après-midi de compétitions intenses
les gymnastes de la gemme elancourt
maurepas termine 5e et arrive à se
maintenir dans le championnat de
division nationale une
l'objectif du club avant le début de la
compétition on est ravis elles font un
match quasi parfait
il ya une petite petite erreur à la base
et cédric pardon on a peur que ça lâche
un peu le match est en fait elle se
ressaisissent très très bien derrière
pour une poutre parfaite et un seul
parfait il ya trois notes qui rentre à
chaque fois sans suite
on a la chance d'être sur une
compétition équipe donc on sait très
bien que si on fait une petite boulette
ya forcément le reste de l'équipe qui
rebondit dernière et c'est ce qui fait
notre force on a tout su rebondir sur
les erreurs des autres
weill en appelle beaucoup au final des
serveurs donc c'était super une première
étape pour le club qui espère désormais
pouvoir viser un podium en division
nationale une dans les prochaines années